[Music]
welcome back to dirty RT it's it's cold
it's windy it's raining it's raining
we're here trying to make Arthur Morgan
aka dirty Artie the biggest POS in the
whole world right now he's rocking no
shoes and he's cooking food like a
mountain man even though there's like a
little civilization right over there
yeah just set up his camp and he's
eating some meat what we're gonna
accomplish in this chapter
gosh this chapter 7 yeah I think so I
think so we thought we'd as we have our
hair pretty long thought we'd treat
ourselves to a little snip snip maybe
just knock out the the mustache just to
you know really bring his beard into
until you see if there's some like
pretty dumb variations of the beard we
can get definitely and then I think
we'll treat ourselves to some drinks at
the local watering hole and then we will
get in a fight with a bear yep yep that
was like one of our first goals of this
is to fight a bear
yeah handed yeah and we figured that
would be a good one to do and maybe we
can do some we can rob some people drunk
while we're getting wasted as well
because people have been asking for that
and we've kind of done it here and there
we don't get anything done yeah that's
pretty much it I know I asked people
like of ideas of like what like what do
you think we should dirty our teacher do
next and I got so many I'm like oh my
god we might be able to do two of these
and like at the rate we complete things
in this will probably do none of them
I'm sure but I think two is is realistic
but we have been getting a lot of people
saying we should we should mess with his
beard see if we can get something
ridiculous so we're gonna knock that out
right away we also did some some prep
work here you should have that Viking
hatchet oh yeah someone Oh someone else
was recommended this is what we did that
let's let's try this bad boy out yeah I
can only diffuse now this is some heavy
heavy verbal uh should have other
hatchets too right
I should have other hatches and oh you
got some dynamite arrows too I did oh
hey ho we watch the whole thing lights
out oh the horses are ok that's good I
mean how do you think you are she was so
shocked you could not handle that Oh get
dirty oh yeah
hey mr. mr. Arthur why are you always so
mad crazy
well that's shooting and they said I was
crazy I'm not crazy
not like you oh yeah you're a nice thick
coat or new on your front side Oh God
look all right let's certainly explore
our options here flying fork okay okay
okay
I hate it I hate that one the most I
really don't want to know you did it
it's too late
yeah it good morning
been a while Oh what it is there it gets
all this is his buddy everyone talking
about maybe not folk reckon luck runs
bad in this time you prestigious among
em reckon that ain't no coincidence
makes his own luck ain't no church no
curse gonna change it but what is this
guy doing your guy shut up
there are my first still got more money
you give me show that's unfortunate they
don't even take you seriously
Oh
[Music]
oh my god after a long night of drinking
uh looks like he's been robbed he has
nothing and we're in the middle of
nowhere
dirty Artie is his hungover and has been
stripped of all of his belongings
well well Jake we better we better get
ourselves back on the right track we
better get some weapons we working some
clothes let's see how far we can get we
are Bear Grylls innit Mondays Oh No
what have we done what happened last
night we kind of blacked out all right
well let's find what's fine some nice
assistants
can't even set up a camp ah you can't we
can't do can you punch this deer with
your bare hands maybe push this rat
No it bit me
skin it yeah just shove it into your
thigh so you know what we could do
though we could follow some smoke yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
well you someone else's camp naked man
right now the woods you have a camp you
give up oh yeah perfect
[Laughter]
so I got your knee deep into this man's
burning carcass we did nothing mmm yeah
what else guy have you have nothing
awesome Oh bread to read chunk perfect
Gor more rum save that up your butt for
later
you should just drink that right now
yeah probably got it I used your camera
okay scream come on get up
hey shake [ __ ] gonna quit oh yeah yeah
no escape that oh it's so sick I don't
pluck the wild turkey maybe it's cuz
I've ran it over so it's just like not
good meat
oh just cook taking good get alright go
hmm mah camp no loading use my invisible
knife this looks so weird save that for
later what's up uh but that's that's
that's a man's real senses but old
[Music]
gender on Oh sick this guy oh no oh it's
in poor condition the one you have maybe
it's not as good okay okay oh hello well
well well put it in there
sure look Sally a deer came in here and
just died Oh oh yeah that horse is dead
all right I say right here
well those deer were right there and
then go run to where they are now after
you drop it that's the hope that's
working here yeah I think right here is
good we checked my up just in case
oh yeah we're right on it yeah
[Music]
I mean so nice behind you yeah alright
I'm saying it on this give us some of
that action so when I could get up to
that things so I could just jump on top
play it safe
sick sick
what didn't kill him oh we're screwed
did he stop the train did they
is there any passengers on this one I
don't know oh my god can't see anything
oh my god oh my god is it stopping in
here and if you have to use your lantern
I guess I don't have a lantern oh no oh
no
and God
Oh police are coming there's my train
rock hurry now got I have to be careful
with ammo huh oh no more please
da-rae now our train
yeah I like this
get down there
that looks fun Oh Oh
we're okay see your body looks so good
yeah let's let's just this water here
throw the body into a hat you first
gotta hide the bodies oh I like that
no matter Oh see if you can write it
down okay should I go there yeah fish
put this up my butt
all right all right all right we'll call
this the chapter I'll do it thank you
guys for watching and stay tuned next
week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]